if they had that for like P.S I love you
or something or like for a rom-com so it
makes no sense but has all these effects
when they're having sex everything's
shaking it starts to smell
it smells like Lube in here it smells
like crabs
so I was like damn this is what Julian
Roberts
[Music]
all right so um down in Brazil for some
weird reason they held a screening of
Titanic but they they did like Titanic
3D because it's new to them oh no it's
it's the 25 year anniversary so it's
going to get re-released in theaters
here too oh wow
the ship comes at you yeah they wanted
to do this whole 3D experience and they
throw water in the [__] Auditorium
funny you should say that sir
oh [__] all right so here's this video
this is um the Titanic 3D screening oh
but guess what this wasn't supposed to
happen there was a storm and it started
to flood the theater
so they thought it was a part of it yeah
that's tied though that's [__] sick
the theater's sinking
they're like yo this is so interactive
that's like the 25th anniversary yeah
there's like flood alarms going out
they're like everybody has to evacuate
they're sitting there like this is sick
don't you think that too is part of the
experience yeah but I mean not all of
them like most people were just they
were just laughing about it because of
the irony like they weren't afraid or
nothing they were because it was
storming that day they know it's raining
outside if that started to happen and
they were just laughing have you guys
seen Titan Titanic recently like the the
graphics and [__] like the boat is it
good it still holds up oh when when it's
like simulating the the bolt coming in
it's like I don't know why but back then
I couldn't see it like I saw a real boat
I was like it's your imagination was
Stronger Yeah but that's well think
about all the [__] we had back then I
mean the computer Graphics back in the
late 90s that's [__] good you know
what I mean that's a real ass [__] of
course we look at it now we got like
[__] like 4K VR shaking my faces deep
fake Titanic well back then it was
clearly like it's clearly not a boat but
I saw it like that looks real
the drugs
he's watching with his love song
it's kind of Darker this movie dude
his little stars aren't accurate in this
movie it turns out it's [__] not even
tight it's like life of pie Richard Fox
hey low-key though I [__] love the
Titanic movie that's just so wait did
you see it when it was new I saw it in
the theaters with my mom and then the
boobies yeah and she'd be like this as
if I wasn't like this yeah trying to
[__] catch a nip dude but that was
such a huge thing that like especially
with Asian parents are excited to go
watch a theater like go watch a movie in
theater of course we're not gonna pay
for it we're moving up somehow yeah or
we're going for the DVD from Asia well
first of all they were two VHS that came
out during that time and you better
believe we had to practice making sure
we rewind it to the exact spot it was if
you had to fast forward to see the
boobies again when your parents weren't
home and then bring it back
but no that it was it's a [__] good
movie all right this is a really great
movie
so long you needed two tapes to finish
the movie yeah that was some [__] that
was that was a weird experience to have
like a double VHS feature that wasn't
like bootleg that you had to rewind with
the [__] plastic color thing yeah you
didn't have the car that you put it in
and you closed the car oh yeah
I was envious of those people
I like that you make it a car like it
couldn't have been any other thing why
is it a car that goes yeah
yeah because it looked like a red like
Corvette little thing they had that for
like kitty beds remember that I was
envious of kids that had beds that were
cars man that was the best or kids that
had bicycles that look like motorcycles
oh
the ultimate Envy and those were hella
cool fake like engine on the side
get your ass people right in that now
the coolest one was like you had a GT
Dino or like a diamondback and it was
all Chrome and then you put pegs on the
front and the back pudding pegs or
something that was real quick and then
you you can have your buddies on and
[__] yeah and you're like a Chinese
circus with like three four kids you
know
the hobbies are [__] spinning plates
[__]
[Laughter]
yeah I mean imagine being in the theater
for something 3D and then that [__]
starts happening that's pretty funny I
feel like I got my money's worth dude I
love I love those 40 experience moves
you don't see them here but they're
always in like China and [__] like that
yeah where it's like 4dx you know like
what the [__] is 40. why don't they
invest in it the whole point is when
you're in there number one if let's say
it's like a war movie and [__] and
you're like sitting in a a [__] you
know a Humvee or something like that
right and the Sea starts shaking and
stuff or then like it goes into a
[__] kitchen and suddenly they spray
out fumes of like smell of rotisserie
chicken and [__] like they just do all
sorts of wild stuff to enhance the
experience totally unnecessary and
probably very expensive for no reason
yeah but just the extra mile is is it's
a fun thing to be I'll pay top dollar
for that you want to go see something
like that yeah I feel like you would
make fun of it really what's the one
when they shot arrows and then you can
feel the wind that's like Indiana Jones
the ride
yeah what movie is that and the drugs
did you guys ever go to Universal and
they had like a Honey I Shrunk the
Audience movie yeah yeah like it was
like honey I struck the kids but instead
like it's like You Get shrunk that's
Disneyland where Captain EO is that a
Disneyland isn't that where Captain EO
used to be in there was Honey I Shrunk
the Audience yeah all of the movie
theater by space not space yes Pokey
with the back or something yeah and then
they would have like a like a snake was
on screen and then they had some like
pipe that went under your legs it felt
like a snake touched your legs basically
that but regular movie so they do that
as a normal thing in China now for for
movies but it's the thing is you have to
there's still a person that has to go
and design a 4D Movie experience so they
gotta still find the time Stamps no one
does shoot the Miss no one to shake the
chairs no one to you know what I'm
saying so it's still a whole thing but
it's [__] sick what movie did you
watch it there that was like that damn I
feel like it was like Midway you know
that war movie oh yeah the ships that's
a good movie by the way sick ass action
stuff I feel like it was that and then
maybe girls trip that [__] would be so
funny if they had that for like P.S I
love you or something yeah or like for a
rom-com so it makes no sense but has all
these effects when they're having sex
everything's shaking it starts to smell
this was like Lube in here it smells
like crabs
I was like yes this is what Julian
Robert's [__] smells like
somebody opened up a can of Nook mom up
in here that would work for Gwyneth
Paltrow though right with her brand
oh for goop because a goop yeah because
she has her vagina scented and a candle
this movie brought to you by goop
manufactured the actual candle that's
supposed to smell like your vagina it's
supposed to smell like her vagine for
sure could you prove that
she's nuts who would do that nuts is an
interesting choice of words and then she
got glitter glitter for her [__] or
something right yeah you could put
glitter
someone's gotta stop her bro this is out
of control and they had the [__]
little like metallic egg beads or
whatever that you put in anyways this is
about the Titans part of the ocean do
you guys like 3D movies
yeah people get dizzy right I don't I
don't care for 3D movies I'd rather just
watch it regular because like the gags
are so like lame like oh it works
I did watch Avatar in 3D
laser three because some movies they
they're meant to kind of be like that
too like Avatar yeah yeah was his way of
the water 3D only two I think so did it
come out yeah dude where the water is
already like top what are you talking
where have you been I've been building a
business he's still got his love song
man no basically it's already in the top
three grossing films of all time it
already passed Titanic way of the water
in the water yeah no it's still in
theaters yeah yeah did you did you like
it I think I thought it was really good
I don't think it was like amazing the
way you said it was like yeah
he was like being nice you guys selling
me boy okay I think it's about a day was
it worth four hours to watch the three
so it's four yeah yeah totally three
hours at the end of the day the time is
not the the true like you know decision
of like how much is worth when you have
to go to 3D IMAX laser whatever that's
when you're like each tick is like 30
bucks yeah you know that's when you're
like okay is this [__] worth but for
three hours of your day bro that's a it
better be a good movie I would rather go
watch a movie that's three hours and
hope in hopes that it's good than like a
[__] 90 minutes get my money's worth
yeah you have three hours to see if it's
good you're like [__] dude wrap it up
it'd be like Cloud Atlas was there a
movie time in jail or not yeah they they
do and then the people look forward to
it yeah bro oh yeah what are some of the
bangers that they were playing [__] Bro
they're [__] playing the minions
grew returns do people ever like
reschedule the riot because it's movie
night
oh my God we're about to kill that no no
they're gonna play they're playing bro
I remember they they played Air Bud do
you guys remember yo they played there's
no way bro it'll get you right yo
everybody's wrong he's like get out of
here we don't want you anymore that
scene bro
are they trying to do that they're
specifically playing really emotional
movies let's try to make it like soften
this up and then and then there was a
Steel Magnolias
yeah there was a yard where they had dog
training what yeah like on a yard so
you're allowed to have like dogs come in
and pet them and all that there's a
there's like a non-profit I forgot the
name of it but they come and they they
help like the inmates the inmates dogs
for dogs
[Laughter]
oh because there was a cholo that got
out of jail and he became like a dog
whisper thing right it's not it's not
that one at all yeah but they would be
it was like they would teach him dog
training and stuff like that you know
what is an adult post-president brand
homeboy you ever had like homeboy salsa
and stuff yeah
and then I think I think that company
also runs a non-profit that works with
people uh out of the system and stuff
yeah they get like free tattoo removal
if you if you have a gang file or like
criminal file um that is though they're
cool but dogs for dogs is coming up yeah
make sure you donate to the kickstarter
dude what's your favorite movie to watch
that they would play
um honestly I I I was mainly like I I
like Air Bud
[Laughter]
that makes sense that they would try to
show more movies that would be like more
like gentle for you rather than like
Prison Break [__] blood and blood out
like Shawshank Redemption over and over
yeah handing out Wooden Spoons and [__]
go ahead and try it
dude don't test us
[Music]